Consider the following game.
Eve instructs Bob
to go into a room.
Bob finds the room empty, except
for some locks, an empty box,
and a single deck of cards.
Eve tells Bob to select
a card from the deck
and hide it as best he can.
The rules are simple.
Bob cannot leave the
room with anything.
Cards and keys all
stay in the room.
And he can put, at most,
one card in the box.
Eve agrees that she has
never seen the locks.
He wins the game if Eve is
unable to determine his card.
So what is his best strategy?
Well, Bob selected a
card, 6 of diamonds
and threw it in the box.
First, he considered the
different types of locks.
Maybe he should lock the
card in the box with the key.
Though, she could pick locks.
So he considers the
combination lock.
The key is on the back.
So if he locks it
and scratches it off,
it seems like the best choice.
But suddenly, he
realizes the problem.
The remaining cards on
the table leak information
about his choice, since it's
now missing from the deck.
The locks are a decoy.
He shouldn't separate
his card from the deck.
He returns his card
to the deck but can't
remember the
position of his card.
So shuffles the deck
to randomize it.
Shuffling is the
best lock because it
leaves no information
about his choice.
His card is now equally likely
to be any card in the deck.
He can now leave the cards
openly in confidence.
Bob wins the game because
the best Eve can do
is simply guess as he
has left no information
about his choice.
Most importantly,
even if we give Eve
unlimited computational
power, she
can't do any better
than a guess.
This defines what we
call perfect secrecy.
On September 1, 1945,
29-year-old Claude Shannon
published a classified
paper on this idea.
Shannon gave the first
mathematical proof
for how and why the one-time
pad is perfectly secret.
Shannon thinks about encryption
schemes in the following way.
Imagine Alice writes a message
to Bob 20 letters long.
This is equivalent to
picking one specific page
from the message space.
The message space can be thought
of as a complete collection
of all possible
20-letter messages.
Anything you can think of
that's 20 letters long,
is a page in this stack.
Next, Alice applies
a shared key which
is a list of 20
randomly-generated shifts
between 1 and 26.
The key space is the
complete collection
of all possible outcomes.
So generating a key is
equivalent to selecting a page
from this stack at random.
When she applies the shifts
to encrypt the message,
she ends up with a ciphertext.
The ciphertext space
represents all possible results
of an encryption.
When she applies the key,
it maps to a unique page
in this stack.
Notice that the size
of the message space
equals the size of
the key space equals
the size of the
ciphertext space.
This defines what we
call perfect secrecy.
For if someone has access to
a page of ciphertext only,
the only thing that they
know is that every message
is equally likely.
So no amount of
computational power
could ever help
improve a blind guess.
Now, the big problem, you're
wondering, with a one-time pad
is we have to share these
long keys in advance.
To solve this problem, we
need to relax our definition
of secrecy by developing a
definition of pseudorandomness.